joining us now the 2020 heisman trophy
winner we don't know his next nfl team
yet but he's a member of team
old spice devonta smith here with us
devante welcome back how are you pal
give me the one word that describes how
you're feeling
two days away from finding out where
your football career is going to
continue
relax
bam relaxed okay that's good all right
so
uh that means somebody that's confident
and and where they might go in the draft
um all right i mean let me ask you this
i'm just as a pure fan i've been wanting
to ask you this just a little bit just
with the heisman trophy all right
what point during the year because it's
such a quarterback award what point
during the year did you look at it and
go
i got a chance to win the heisman trophy
or i'm legit contender here was there a
moment that happened
um i'd probably say after the arkansas
game after my own purpose
that that was the game that you said you
thought that it it was the jump off
point
yeah
all right i'm checking out your stats in
that arkansas game
all right so wow okay so you think that
that you're you didn't have a lot of
receptions that game but you thought the
punt return
helped do it
yeah all right it's fitting that you
want a quarterback award because you
wear a quarterback number and now
at the next level you can take six with
you the fans have to know devante when
it's time to buy the new smith jersey is
it going to be number six
that's what i hope
if it's not what's your second choice if
it's not six if six is already taken
with the team that drafts you
um
probably three
damn so he's going single digits all the
way why why six and three i i've never
heard you really answer that
um i wore three
all through middle school and high
school
okay and then what you just went i'm
going to get to college and be twice as
good and i'm going to go to number six
three was already taken so i think six
was the next thing okay all right
all right you know i'm always interested
devonte and like
you know just
like
peel back the curtain for people who
watch the show we talk about nick saban
we talk about you a lot like what is it
like being coached by him
on a daily basis like the energy the
things he's taught you just give us a
little clue there
um i mean it's great just i mean he's
the best at what he do
and it's just like you get the
opportunity to be coached by the best
and just to see how he views things and
see how his mind thinks and i mean once
you talk to him and just get an
understanding of why he acts the way he
acts it's basically like he's doing it
all for the right reason
hey you know sims is going to eventually
ask you this if i don't but i gotta know
do you have the outfit picked out for
thursday night give us an idea give us a
preview give us a sense of what you're
gonna be wearing when that name gets
announced and we see devonta smith
officially as a member of the nfl
oh it's gonna be a surprise you gotta
wait and see
oh so we're gonna oh okay so there we
got photos of you we got evidence of you
dressed up oh here we got a little
double breasted like that that's that's
classic oh
little like volunteer orange here with
the black uh uh the black turtleneck oh
look at you
damn versatility
that that's impressive all right i like
it so i'm expecting something good along
those lines you're definitely going coat
and all that all right so
i we know you dress good have you bought
anything worth a damn yet like anything
good i'm talking like you know real good
cars money watch what are we doing here
nah
and
nothing at all nothing at all you
chicken i can't believe you jeez all
this money old spice gonna be giving you
and all this you haven't bought anything
man
hey davonte how much time have you spent
how much time have you spent thinking
about which team you're going to play
for next cause it's not up to you you
got to wait and see who picks you
do you have some thoughts as to where
you may go
no i just let it everything's going on
playing as it's supposed to go so i mean
just sit back and just let things flow
um
slim reaper is that right the slim
reaper is that what you're called that's
what that's the word on the street
where'd that come from come on let me
hear it let me hear the story behind it
slim reaper oh
i honestly don't don't know who was the
first person to say
it just like it just kind of came up i
just i posted some on instagram and just
the comments that's what everybody was
saying so who's the person that first
person they call me that i have no clue
all right i'm gonna i'm using it i'm
gonna use it for now on so just so you
know it's we're gonna make it stick
hey devonta make sure make sure you get
your lawyers to register the trademark
before sims does and start selling the
jerseys you need to get paid for it
um
who is it that you look up to the most
in the nfl that you want to be like when
you get to that level
um i'll say keenan allen
ooh
why's that
um just the detail and everything he
does from his releases to his route
running just his overall understanding
of the game i mean just everything he he
does i vision myself doing the same
thing i feel myself as the same player
yeah the route running i could see that
i could see why why you like him for
sure um you know
i want to just switch gears to like a
little bit about your quarterback right
have you been paying attention to some
of the backlash
about him being picked at number three i
mean people sounds like some people
might jump off bridges like what do you
have to say to defend like mac jones if
he were to be picked at number three by
the san francisco 49ers
i mean
the resume speaks for itself we not have
to throw the ball to ourselves so i mean
he's a great quarterback he's a great
guy one of the first guys in the
building last guy so i mean
why everybody's doing this i don't know
what i mean apparently they couldn't
have been watching too much football
yeah exactly apparently right
hey davonte tell us what you got going
on with old spice
um i'm proud to partner with spikes
they're committed to helping guys build
confidence to reach their true potential
and um
they partner with big brother big sister
who's put a spotlight on mentorship and
like myself i have a mentor and
it's helped me a lot so just people that
need mentorship need mentors to help
them get through the things they give
you you know you can visit
one.com to learn more
that is awesome we've been big old spice
fans for years and i've always been a
believer in big brother's big sister
it's great to see two great groups like
that come together devonta i got a
question for you
and before i ask you let me tell you
this we we are
on team devonta completely we don't
think what you weigh when you get on the
scale means jack diddly you know what
you're a great football player people i
talk to around the league can't wait to
see what you do when you went to
indianapolis did you know they were
going to put you on a scale
yeah
do you got a problem with the fact that
that number got out
no not at all because i mean i i know
what it is they don't bother me at all
[Laughter]
like
you really i love that you're not
bothered by it i could tell that from
day one like you you don't sweat one
minute or or stay up at night at all but
like you got to be sick of answering
this damn question right like can you
give us like an example and again don't
tell the team or anything but like is it
you know is this always come up in every
conversation with the team like tell me
like how they approach this subject with
you always
um
honestly not many teams
really said anything about it you had
something teams that just said like
they're not worried about it and things
like that and so i'm just asking like
how i go about it but um overall nobody
really had like big concerns over
okay that's good to hear
do you have a concern that like if you
would put on 15 or 20 pounds just to
shut people up you would give up too
much of your game
no i mean i don't think about me and
wait i mean it comes to come
i just go about it and it is what it is
i don't think about adding weight at all
yeah all right so you're not worried
about it it's not something that you're
looking at towards your career and going
i'm going to put on i mean because i
always thought like don't put on weight
because i don't want i want you to still
run a 4-3 that's that's what i worried
about but
you know you don't seem to care either
way you're just going to continue to be
devante smith huh
that's right that's right that's damn
right that's right he's going to be
devante smith and show everybody what
the hell he's got that's right i like it
we're on your team man all right i want
to ask i wanted to ask you a follow this
before all right and i know you got to
go but
like the nick saban stuff
for like devonta smith how did he treat
you does he like is he a needler like
does he needle you like and tease you
and tell you things you need to get
better at or is he just up front and in
your face i mean how did he kind of
motivate you and approach devonte smith
um it was kind of both i mean
when needed he get on me just like he
did on everybody else but overall i mean
he's a funny guy i mean he jokes with
everybody he gets on everybody he
doesn't treat nobody different from the
next person so i mean he gets home he
laughs with me he jokes with me just all
depends on the situation
yeah
devante last one for me best advice
you've gotten
to prepare you for what's coming and who
gave you that advice
um just continue to be myself i mean i
had a lot of people to tell me that just
continue to be me what's got me here
just keep doing that
hey that's great advice and it's
definitely worked for you it's gotten
you to the heisman trophy in the brink
of being a high first round pick in the
2021 nfl draft we congratulate you on
all your success we're very excited to
see where you're going to end up and
thanks to you and to old spice and the
big brothers big sister for making you
available devonta all the best on
thursday night and beyond
appreciate it you're the man divided
rookies all rookies got to send us free
old spice gear okay so just make sure
you get that in the meal and then mail
all right come on man
all right man see you good luck
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports